so burial is basically like an instagram
dog mom
[Music]
suberial cebario we all know his name
and not necessarily how to pronounce it
okay minor spoilers
for words of radiance i will be
discussing a minor character in words of
radiance but is he really that much of a
minor character when he
reaches into our hearts and says you you
too have a friend in the diamond
business he doesn't say that but i feel
like he's the type of person who would
i love brandon sanderson but i have to
admit with a few exceptions
he writes about people who want to do
the right thing
even when it's very difficult and then
you have a character
who transcends the rules of sanderson's
universe who
who breaks the bonds of what is right
and wrong i'm going to say he's chaotic
neutral
because because that's what that that's
that that's how he strikes me
siberia is an individual in words of
radiance who
shalon uses now we all know about shalon
she's a bit of a user she knows how to
work her way
into a situation that benefits her and
siberia
acknowledges this and respects it
because he is
first and foremost a businessman and as
a businessman
in a world full full of honor men like
dalinar who are trying to follow honor
all these radiants all of these
religious zealots
siberia stands alone in his
pure unadulterated love of chill
time suberial is a twitch streamer
so burial is basically like an instagram
dog mom he's just living his best
life he's got his his mistress polona
who he lives with
who let's be real polona runs
you know his [ __ ] war camp let's be
real here polona
is the real important one they make such
a good
partnership and team and let's just say
relationship of the whole series
series they have what people strive for
in a relationship dalinar is this
perfect foil to suberial
so perfect what happens in the story i
won't spoil it how siberia
comes into the story at just the right
time
and it's just it just builds such a
perfect moment for dalinar and
burial what i admire and love about
siberia within this
world is that while everyone is fighting
after gem hearts
getting rich these certain ways suberial
thinks outside the box
burial and polona think outside the box
while these people are getting rich off
of these gem hearts he knew he had big
brain he had chest
brain these people these armies here on
the shadow planes they're gonna have to
eat
right they're gonna have to survive
they're gonna have their families
there's gonna be need to be commerce and
trading
and who's going to be there when they
need supplies farming and doing the
boring [ __ ]
[ __ ] suberial now yes now in her
notes
says that he's obnoxious he's a fool
he's unhelpful he's a coward yes yes yes
he's obnoxious he's a coward and we love
him all the more because of it
because so burial is us
he's real and more specifically he's us
in this century you know we sit around
we [ __ ] record youtube videos what do
we do
we watch youtube we sit around we go on
our zoom meetings
we eat grapes just like like a greek
person just in olden times we are
so burial now you know way back then you
had people like what back then this is a
fictional world but i'm saying
in the fantasy world you got people like
caledon and dalinar and shalon
doing crazy epic [ __ ] in the real world
he got some burial the scummy people
making millions of dollars do you know
what
i think this is why i personally love
suberial so much
today in our modern times we have these
millionaires billionaires rich people
the high princess so-called the jeff
bezos is the elon musk
talking about how important their ideas
are about how important their opinions
are about the important work they're
doing around the world
and they're [ __ ] billionaires and i
personally believe that billionaires are
leeches
on society the high princes in the
stormlight archive are
leeches off of society okay they add
absolutely no
value to their society i have to love
any wealthy person like that any high
prince to be
straightforward no [ __ ] about what
he's there to do he's there to extract
the resources to
make more money and in the meantime he
doesn't have any goals he doesn't have
any honor he isn't trying to save
anybody or anything he acknowledges what
his scummy
stupid purpose is on earth and as a
result he's going to sit back
kick back his feet and [ __ ] enjoy
life okay he's the only rich person
in this whole series with any [ __ ]
sense okay and you'll see that during
very climactic moment in the story
and so burial is just reclining
and enjoying life because what else can
you do all right
no [ __ ] pretense props to him and
shalon
for getting a kind of bond because
let's say shalon is the person with like
the most lies
she is the most hidden the most
secretive and then you have suberial who
is just the most blunt and obvious
does not give a [ __ ] kind of person he's
just got one one
face and that's a burial together they
can kind of see through the [ __ ]
because
deep down there are layers just some
burial
fear you know a goal towards honorable
things so-called but he doesn't pretend
that that's the main thing because he
understands maybe i'm projecting a
little bit
he understands how this society works he
and shalon
they have this connection and they're
able to do business together so to speak
because
they understand each other's [ __ ] he
knows that shalon
is just bullshitting that's all she does
because inna says that's all he does too
as real as he is i don't know where this
came from or what this
is intending to do or why but i have to
say
i feel really smart for having said all
of this
i have revealed the essence of the most
important character i have discussed
siberia i've
elevated his character into world
view suberial and polona
without them in the stormlight archive
without them in words of radiance this
book would be a one out of five
i am so glad to have been here and
discuss this with you i feel like we've
built a real connection here
so if you want to like and subscribe
that's totally uh
a thing you could do you know i wouldn't
feel awkward if you like and subscribe
that i would
feel honored thanks for watching
that was a good video